l'état doit retrouver le sens de
l'anticipation dans son discours de
politique générale jean castex a donc
confirmé le grand retour du commissariat
général au plan sa mission définir une
perspective et identifier les futurs
gisements de croissance a dit le nouveau
premier ministre
alors faut-il voir dans ce retour du
plan un gadget politique ou un véritable
tournant pour notre économie
on en parle de ce pas avec vous jacques
sapir en duplex de notre studio du
quartier de l'opéra
soyez le bienvenu jacques bonjour
stéphanie alors jeanne vous avez été un
grand spécialiste de l'économie
soviétique ce retour du plan cela vous
vous parle que faut-il en penser
oui effectivement ça me parle alors il
faut tout de suite dire que la
planification française n'avait
strictement rien à voir avec la
planification soviétique l'économie
soviétique c'était une économie
planifiée
alors que la planification française
effectivement c'était un système qui
devait je dirais assurer une
coordination entre les efforts faits par
l'état par le secteur public et les
efforts faits par le secteur privé
donc là effectivement on a eu ce qu'on
appelle l'ardente obligation du plan de
en fait jusqu'à 2006 en réalité ça a été
un petit peu moins puisque le plan n'a
été pertinent que jusqu'à la fin des
années 70 c'est au début des années 1980
mais il a donné quand même d'assez bons
résultats alors jacques en quoi
consistait ce plan qui accompagnait les
trente glorieuses et même au delà
alors justement il faut savoir que le
plan c'était en réalité une idée qui
était déjà à la main c'était une idée
qui était dans l'air du temps par
exemple dans les années 30 ce qui s'est
passé c'est que après guerre au moment
de la libération est bien évidemment une
première chose qui a d'une certaine
manière imposer l'idée du plan c'était
tout simplement l'ampleur de la
reconstruction qu'il y avait à faire
après beaucoup d'économistes et même des
hommes politiques ont dit mais il ne
s'agit pas simplement de reconstruire
on ne peut pas d'une certaine manière
retournez à la france de 1939 il va
falloir modernisé il va falloir
progresser
réindustrialiser la france et donc c'est
aussi pour cela que la planification a
été lancé et comme je voulais dit
évidemment cette planification
elle a finalement donné d'assez bons
résultats alors quand on parle d'une
planche qu'on évoque également des
échecs cuisants comme le plan calcul des
années 60 alors est ce que c'est une si
bonne idée que cela de ressusciter le
plan on peut se poser la question
oui alors effectivement vous avez tout à
fait raison c'est fini de parler de
l'échec du plan calcul même si c'est en
réalité un demi échec il faut savoir
simplement que le plan calcul il a été
d'une certaine manière le produit des
militaires il a été le produit d'un
espèce d'impératif militaire c'était la
dissuasion
en fait on voulait des ce qu'on a fait
des calculateurs on n'appelait pas
encore ça est réellement des des
ordinateurs pour faire l'ensemble des
calculs qui permettrait à la france de
se doter de la bombe à hydrogène
c'est ça fonctionnait dans le domaine
militaire
évidemment ça n'a pas fonctionné dans le
domaine civil c'est pour ça que je
considère que le plan calcul ça a été un
demi échec
maintenant il faut savoir que les plans
en règle générale on était des grands
succès il ne faudrait pas du tout que
cet arbre du plan calcul cache ses
succès le premier plan qui est le plan
fait par jean monnet le premier haut
commissaire il a permis de jeter les
bases de la reconstruction de mieux
utiliser d'ailleurs l'aide américaine du
plan marshall et de construire les
infrastructures le deuxième plan le plan
hirsch du nom du deuxième haut
commissaire et bien ce plan lire il a
été consacrée essentiellement au
développement de la recherche
développement de l'éducation mais aussi
de la modernisation de l'agriculture
quelque chose qui était extrêmement
important dans une france où il est bien
les agriculteurs représenter 30% de la
population active en 1946 et puis les
troisième et quatrième plan qui
conscients qu'ils correspondent en fait
au début de la vème république c'était
des plans sous la direction de jean macé
ça a été des plans qui ont été d'une
certaine manière dédiée au développement
des industries de consommation mais
aussi et surtout à l'amélioration
extrêmement importante de la
compétitivité de
l'économie française alors jacques
aujourd'hui à quoi servirait un tel plan
alors si on reprend les déclarations que
ce soit celle d'emmanuel macron ou celle
de jean castex
on voit très bien qu'il y a en fait deux
grandes priorités
nous devons retrouver notre souveraineté
en particulier dans le domaine de la
santé et des industries sanitaires et
puis il y à ce grand programme pour
assurer la transition énergétique
alors bien évidemment ces deux grands
projets nécessitent le type de
coordination entre le secteur public et
le secteur privé qui implique d'une
certaine manière un commissariat au plan
on le voit bien dans le domaine de la
santé où il faudra non seulement
évidemment comme on y produire des
masses pour dire des respirateurs
produit du matériel pour les tests il
faudra d'une certaine manière développer
de manière très importante cette filière
pour assurer la souveraineté et
l'indépendance nationale et puis dans le
domaine de la transition énergétique
il s'agit d'une certaine manière
d'accélérer le passage à des ide un des
énergies non carbonées accélérer le
développement de la filière à hydrogène
là encore on ne voit que selon hra que
cela aura des conséquences structurantes
extrêmement importantes sur l'économie
française
prenons par exemple l'un des points qui
a été évoqué par le président de la
république lors de son interview il a
parlé de sa volonté de re développer le
fret ferroviaire de redévelopper les
trains dits de campagne les trains de
nuit
bref on voit bien qu'il y à là à travers
ce re développement du rail qui est une
chose extrêmement important il y à bien
une notion d'aménagement du territoire
et justement l'aménagement du territoire
c'était la deuxième jambe du plan car
avec le commissariat général au plan
eh bien nous avions aussi la délégation
à l'action territoriale et à l'action
rural la datar qui a joué un rôle au
moins aussi important que le
commissariat général au plan pour une
certaine manière structurée
l'ensemble de l'espace économique
français donc en clair mans
croyez à la planification jacques sépare
tellement la question de croire ou de ne
pas quoi si vous voulez c'est de
constater que la planification d'une
certaine forme de planification et bien
ça fonctionne ça fonctionnait en france
mais ça fonctionnait aussi dans d'autres
pays on peut prendre par exemple le cas
du japon le cas de la corée du sud par
exemple
maintenant ce qu'il faut dire aussi
c'est qu'il ne faudrait pas que cette
idée ne servent en fait au gouvernement
car réaliser un espèce de coup de
communication
si on veut effectivement ressusciter le
commissariat général au plan est dit il
faudra lui donner du pouvoir
il faudra lui donner une forme de
contrôle sur les investissements publics
il faudra lui donner du pouvoir pour
qu'il négocie avec le secteur privé
d'égal à égal
on voit que d'une certaine manière c'est
une idée qui impose d'une certaine
manière des choix importants
et justement c'est la question est ce
que ces choix
le gouvernement est il prêt à les faire
et la question évidemment aussi est-ce
que cela peut fonctionner aujourd'hui
effectivement et on pense immédiatement
aux règles de l'union européenne parce
que il est clair si vous voulez que
cette planification en dix ans ce crs de
nouveau commissariat général au plan
et bien il va devoir intervenir dans des
domaines où existe en réalité toute une
série de réglementations européennes
par exemple les réglementations sur la
concurrence le commissariat général au
plan pourrait vouloir lever ces
réglementations pourrait vouloir imposer
peut-être de manière partielle peut-être
de manière temporaire
certaines mesures de type
protectionnistes bref on voit très bien
qu'il n'ya pas de cohérence à dire
souveraineté européenne est à dire dans
le même temps eh bien on veut recréer
une planification
vous savez c'est très joli de dire je
vais me réinventer mais encore faut-il
apporter des preuves
et là nous n'avons aucune preuve que
emmanuel macron est réellement prêts à
assumer ce que signifierait la
recréation de ce commissariat général au
plan
alors justement on parle beaucoup de
regrets
le poste de haut commissaire au plan
cela devrait être annoncée avec la suite
de la formation du gouvernement de jean
castex et on parle de nommer une
personnalité politique de premier plan
qu'ont pensez vous alors oui pourquoi
pas recréer effectivement ce poste de
haut commissaire au plan un poste
d'ailleurs le haut commissaire au plan
avec statut quasiment deux ministres et
il participait en tant que tel au
conseil des ministres
mais après c'est pas tellement la
question du nom qui est important c'est
la question des attributions qui l'aura
c'est la question du périmètre d'action
qui l'aura et donc c'est sur tous ces
points qui sont des points extrêmement
sensible que l'on attend effectivement
des choses précises de la part du
gouvernement est effectivement temps
qu'on en saura pas plus eh bien on
pourra toujours avoir un doute sur la
personne évidemment n'est très curieux
on parle beaucoup par exemple de
françois bayrou comme haut commissaire
alors voilà c'est un des bruits qui lie
actuellement et c'est un et bruit qu'il
faut penser qu'on serait plutôt face à
un coup de communication
c'est pas que j'ai quoi que ce soit
contre françois bayrou qui a été
d'ailleurs un très bon ministre de
l'éducation nationale tous les cas un
ministre qui était nettement supérieur à
nombre de ses successeurs
mais enfin les premiers commissaire au
plan
si on excepte jean monnet et encore les
premiers commissaires au plan des gens
comme etienne hirsch par exemple ou pire
pierre macé où michelle albert ou pire
ivko sait encore qui est une
personnalité avec laquelle j'ai un petit
peu travaillé dans les années 1990
c'était tous des hauts fonctionnaires
c'étaient tous des gens qui étaient
choisis sur leurs compétences sur leur
maîtrise de leur domaine et non pas sur
un je dirais une image politique donc
c'est là où on voit effectivement
l'ampleur du problème est en fait ce que
l'on peut se dire c'est que la personne
qui aurait peut-être le meilleur profil
pour être le haut commissaire
c'est le premier ministre actuel c'est
monsieur jean castex qui correspond tout
à fait à ce type de définition mais qui
se trouve être justement le premier
ministre
alors j'ai pour conclure je me sens
plutôt réservé sur ce retour du plan on
peut dire ça comme ça
alors réservez non mais je dois dire que
j'ai une crainte c'est que cette idée de
recréer de ressusciter le commissariat
général plan qui est unique qui est une
bonne idée qui est une idée dont nous
avons besoin c'est absolument
incontestable et bien que cette idée
elles ne servent en fait qu'à faire un
espèce de coup de pub un espèce de coup
de communication
et si cela devait être le cas eh bien ça
serait assez grave parce que cela aurait
fait perdre un temps précieux à
l'économie française car de toutes les
manières il nous faudra bien et le plus
tôt sera le mieux
recréer un organisme qui est la fonction
du commissariat général au plan merci
jacques on verra évidemment ce que
l'avenir nous dira de cette idée merci à
vous